- Watch, she's moving.
- [Wes] Have you ever tried
to roll over a thousand-pound
unconscious elephant seal?
- Up up, get her up and over.
Hold her nose really tight.
- I hadn't either.
Take it from me, it's not easy.
(lively music)
- I'm Wes Larson, a wildlife biologist
and lover of the outdoors for
as long as I can remember.
I'm traveling the country to find
the next generation of conservationists,
the people on the front lines of the fight
to understand our planet
and protect the animals
we share it with.
This time around I'm on the West Coast,
just North of Monterey Bay.
I'm meeting up with an
elephant seal research team
at The University of
California Santa Cruz.
Hey.
- Hey, good morning.
- Good morning.
- Nice to see you.
We got a busy day ahead,
so if you could grab one of these jackets
and then we will head up to the beach.
- [Wes] Rachel Holser has
been studying elephant seals
at the Costa lab for four years
and believes tracking elephant seals
could hold the key to
a deeper understanding
of the ocean as a whole.
Our mission this morning is to attach
some high-tech tracking
tags to an elephant seal,
but not just any seal will do.
- We are a little bit particular
about the animals we
put satellite tags on,
so an adult female over 4 years old
and under 13 years old,
hasn't been tracked before,
and has been on the
beach for nearly a month.
- In short they are looking for a seal
that has had her pup and is ready
to head back out into the sea.
Rachel tells me that there
are seven promising candidates
on the beach today, which
sounds like a lot to me,
but then I see the colony
for the first time.
We just kinda rounded this hill
and suddenly all these seals
are spread out in front of us.
One thing that's super surprising
is the amount of
vocalization that's going on,
all the seals kind of talking
to each other out here.
(seals making sounds)
It's a lot to take in.
The seals are big, loud, and
absolutely cover the beach.
- Take binos, take a
re-site data book, for sure,
and yeah, we'll see what we can find.
- The researchers are fanning out.
They're just going seal to seal
trying to find the particular female
that they're trying to tag today.
- [Wes] The couple thousand
seals on the beach.
It's like looking for a needle
in a very noisy, potentially
dangerous hay stack,
but it's worth the risk.
It turns out, if you wanna study
the farthest reaches of the ocean,
elephant seals are natural
deep-sea explorers.
- They go way out into the
middle of the North Pacific,
and they dive far deeper than
anybody thought was possible.
- [Wes] And eventually,
Rachel spots the perfect seal.
- If you're looking straight down,
there's two animals back to back.
One has a pup nursing on her right side.
I think that that is her.
We had a good look at her.
So we're estimating her
mass at about 340 kilograms.
So we're gonna pull up a
3.4 cc dose of Telazol.
- And so you physically just go up
and put the needle in 'em.
- Yep.
That is how this goes.
- That's a big needle.
That's to get through all that blubber.
- Yeah, exactly.
- There's a big male over there.
It's actually the alpha
male of this colony,
so we're kinda just waiting for them
to get positioned in a way
to where the researchers
can go in, sedate the seal,
and then attach their tag.
This is the most dangerous
part of the research.
Rachel has to inject the sedative by hand,
and elephant seals can be unpredictable.
- They are very dangerous animals.
I know they look pretty lazy and sleepy
if they're on a beach, but they can move
surprisingly quickly and
react surprisingly quickly.
And the big guys, you know,
the males, are almost two tons,
and they can run as fast
as a person can run.
We spend years being trained
to work with them properly.
- Did you get the seal stuck?
- Yes, we did.
(lively music)
- Oh oh, just keep a
light hand on her nose
just in case she pulls out again.
- There's a bunch of different
things going on right now.
It's pretty impressive.
Theresa's taking these
ultrasound measurements
with the blubber.
These two collaborators
are putting on the epoxy
for this tag that we're attaching
to get that oceanographic data.
And then on top we're
also attaching a VHF tag.
Rachel's kinda organizing everyone
and directing everyone
to do what they're doing.
- Grab another popsicle stick.
- [Wes] Meanwhile, as always,
we have all these other seals,
so we kind of always have
to be keeping an eye on
to make sure that no one's coming up
and aggressively kind of
challenging the group.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Thank you, Patrick.
We've been monitoring the
population at Año Nuevo
for between three and four decades now.
But if the elephant
seals are not doing well
that means that something
is really going sideways
down in the food web.
- We got another seal kind
of creeping back here.
Alright, so yeah, one of
the really cool things
about these tags is
they're actually recording
oceanographic information with them.
All sorts of things that
they would normally record
with like a really
expensive research vessel,
they're using these seals
kinda as that research vessel.
And elephant seals make
exceptionally good research vessels.
After they leave the colony
they swim out into the
Pacific for thousands of miles
diving over a mile below the surface.
And all the while the tags
will be collecting data.
What you end up with is a
three-dimensional profile
of the ocean.
That is, if all goes as planned.
It's just so crazy to
have, like, this happening
20 feet away, 10 feet away,
as we're working on this seal.
At times it reminded me of being in an ER.
- [Woman Offscreen] Half cc kit.
- And others, it was like
being on another planet
surrounded by hostile aliens.
(elephant seal growling)
One thing that's really interesting
is this kind of like matador
act that they have going on.
It's just a tarp.
I mean if the thing wanted to
come through they totally can.
And so at all points we have to be ready
to kind of back off and run away
if one of these seals kind of
crosses that threshold of safety.
Through the chaos the team gets it done,
deploying three different tags
and giving the seal a full checkup.
- Alright, you guys can
go ahead and roll her
on Theresa's count.
OK, go ahead.
Good, breath.
Go ahead and pull it.
- So far, so good.
With the science complete
there's one important step left:
waiting for our seal to wake up.
- We'll stay nearby, so that if a male
decides to try and mate
with her, we can prevent it.
We're fully responsible for
the well-being of the animal
until she is capable of
taking care of herself.
So, it looks like our
female's doing really well.
She's recovering nicely.
She's moved back into the group.
And hopefully, in about three days,
she'll head off to sea and
give us lots of awesome data.
- [Wes] Looking out at the
colony it's hard to imagine
that a hundred years ago elephant
seals nearly disappeared.
- [Rachel] They did almost go extinct
back in the early 1900s.
Once the seal was protected and hunting
was no longer permitted, they rebounded
and they have been spreading ever since.
- [Wes] And now you guys are using them
in all these kind of new novel ways
to learn more about the ocean,
to protect other species.
- [Rachel] Yeah, absolutely.
- I found that conservation success
can sometimes be as simple
as changing perceptions.
Rachel and her team have shown
that an animal that appears
to just lie around on a beach
is actually an incredible
traveler and athlete.
And by harnessing their power
we are able to gain a deeper
understanding of the ocean.
It makes me wonder how
else we could be working
with wildlife to protect the
planet that we all share.